what's going on people today we're
breaking down the alternate timeline of
attack on titan in which ervin was the
one chosen to inherit the colossal
this video will explain how he and the
rest of the scouts would try to defend
the island from a global invasion and
why they wouldn't be able to rely on the
rumbling for their survival before we
get into it though it should be said
that this is the fourth part of an
ongoing series so if you want to see the
entire ultimate timeline so far then the
playlist is in the description
also final thing is that i'm giving away
free attack on titan merge to one person
watching this video and all you have to
do to enter is simply sub to the channel
and leave a comment below as long as you
are subscribed your comment has a chance
of being randomly selected just like
this person who won the previous
giveaway we did
okay so part 4 continues directly on
from the last video with the cart tyson
lunging forward to kill zeke in this
secret underground prison because the
location of this prison was well hidden
by the scout it's currently a mystery
how pique was able to find it but for
now the main thing we need to focus on
is that she does actually eat the beast
titan by chewing through his spine she
merges the strength of their two
shifters into one and more importantly
zeke's death means the ld has lost its
only titan of royal blood without that
power it's now physically impossible for
aaron to activate the rumbling meaning
that the rest of the global alliance can
now attack the island without the fear
of their countries being trampled
meanwhile in shiganshina irvin would be
in a meeting with historia and the titan
shift unit but they'd be interrupted by
a random soldier bursting into the room
the soldier would reveal that minutes
ago a transmission was received from
zeke's location in which a guard
confirmed they were taking fire from
foreign airships news like that would
definitely get a strong reaction from
everyone in the room with aaron in
particular being more furious than
anyone it's not that he's necessarily
worried about zeke but rather aaron
knows that if something bad happens to
his brother then the military will
replace him by turning historia into a
royal blooded titan that's why he'd be
so angry in this moment cause by the
enemy targeting the prison the knock-on
effect is that it puts her in danger as
well
as a result aaron would turn to the
commander and demand that they save the
beast titan because if his sibling is
still alive then the jagabros can
activate the rumbling once and for all
louise and flock would also be in full
support of this idea but by now evan
would have a different plan since he's
realized something that no one else has
like i mentioned earlier zee's location
was a state secret meaning the only
people who knew the coordinates were
high-ranking military officials
high-ranking members of the azmobito
clan and obviously the gods were working
there therefore for the prison to be
attacked at least one person from these
groups must have betrayed the island for
that reason evan suspects that either
historia or aaron will be the enemy's
next target and he'd want them both to
stay far far away from the prison
instead the commander himself and flock
will be the ones to travel to the jail
to potentially save zeke while all the
other shifters will stay behind to
protect the queen
now switching over to their global
alliance for a second after receiving
confirmation of zeke's death the rest of
their forces would begin approaching ldr
from the south these forces would
include dozens of powerful warships as
well as a fleet of aircraft that would
be making their way towards the walls
on board one of these aircrafts would be
willie tiber who has a personal grudge
against eren for killing his sister back
in liberio
as we saw in part 3 part of the reason
he helped to form this global alliance
was because he and pique wanted to
avenge their family who were murdered by
the scouts in pete's case she now has
that revenge for her father's death
after killing both zeke and jon but
willy's revenge won't be complete until
they finally deal with aaron himself
anyway about an hour later the
alliance's airships would arrive in
shigachina causing the local civilians
to go into mass panic
huge crowds of innocent people would run
away from the invasion and it wouldn't
take long for the sounds of their
screams to be heard inside the fort this
place is where the shifter unit would be
watching over historia but after hearing
all the chaos outside aaron would go to
the window to take a look on the streets
he see thousands of his fellow islanders
running for their lives while in the sky
there'd be a bunch of foreign soldiers
parachuting out of airships
immediately aaron would notice a few
strange things about these soldiers with
the first being that they have large
mysterious packages strapped to their
backs from a distance it'd be hard for
him to tell what exactly these packages
are but given there are so many of them
it's obviously not going to be anything
good
within minutes the enemy would then use
these handles to maneuver themselves so
that every single one of them lands on
top of war mario in that way the whole
of shiganshino would now be surrounded
by enemy fighters standing on the wall
which sets the stage for the next phase
of this attack
through the window historia and the
others would watch on in disbelief as
the mysterious packages turn out to
actually be people all across the wall
the alliance soldiers would force these
people to kneel in front of them in a
moment that would remind aaron of things
he's witnessed in his father's past
memories just like in those memories the
people in the present day would be
violently injected against their will
indicating that their most likely
subjects of emir
following the injection their bodies
would be kicked towards the ground which
is a 50 meter drop and as they fall down
the entire district will light up from
literally every direction a second later
countless pure titans would reign onto
their houses below causing many civilian
casualties just from the impact alone by
smashing into the surface it'd create
massive amounts of debris that would
just fly everywhere and as people
continue to panic it's unavoidable that
some unlucky individuals would get
trampled by the crowd
at the same time although one or two
pure titans might have died from the
fall the vast majority of them would
begin rampaging through the town with
willy tyber observing this massacre from
his airship by this point you're likely
wondering how all of this destruction
benefits him and the answer is that it's
part of his strategy to lure out the
founding titan
thanks to the traitor that's been
passing on information willie knew that
today the shifter unit was scheduled to
have a meeting somewhere in shiganshina
with all of elder shifters being in one
place on one day it presented the
alliance with a great chance to wipe
them out and these pure titans are the
key to making that happen
by unleashing them into the district
willy suspects that eren won't be able
to just stand by and watch meaning it's
only a matter of time until the attack
titan and the other shifters reveal
themselves
when it comes to irvine he and flock
would have spent the last hour riding as
fast as they can alongside levi sasha
and a handful of other scouts
as we know their primary aim right now
is to save the beast titan but in the
time that it's taken for them to travel
flock would start to have doubts about
whether this mission is a lost cause in
spite of that everyone would remind
everyone that even if it's too late to
save zeke they can still achieve their
secondary objective of finding out who
the enemy is
eventually after enough riding the group
would make it to the prison and upon
arrival they noticed foreign soldiers
standing guard as well as several
airships circling overhead
this would cause irvine to become
majorly skeptical about the enemy's
intentions because they're actively
choosing to hang around rather than
trying to escape with the beast titan
in order to find out what's really going
on the commander would devise a plan to
infiltrate the jail which involves him
and flock using their titans
an important thing that the commander
would know about this prison is that it
has two separate entrances one in this
area near the front and a different one
towards the back
therefore evan's plan is to cause such a
huge distraction in this area that the
enemy would have no choice but to focus
all their energy in that direction this
would give levi and the others time to
fight their way through the back
entrance and hopefully find zeke in the
process
to get things started the commander
would run out into the open field in
full view of the enemy soldiers and he'd
be charging at the base in his human
form by making himself this visible it
would instantly put all of the
alliance's attention on him with more
soldiers gathering near the front to see
what's going on
as he runs further and further into the
field pique would desperately order the
alliance to fire their anti-tying
cannons but before they can do that evan
would activate a lightning fast
transformation
in his colossal titan form the commander
would reach out to all the airships that
were circling the prison and one by one
he'd smash them to pieces
meanwhile on the ground flock would
initiate the next stage of this plan as
he transforms into the armored titan and
sprints towards the main entrance
within a few seconds he'd be using his
bare hands to smash through several of
the enemy cannons and soldiers and levi
and sasha would use this distraction to
sneak into the jail
however while flock continues his
rampage he'd eventually be caught by
surprise as these two soldiers managed
to fire at him from point-blank range in
this scenario there simply wouldn't be
enough space for the armored titan to
evade the attack and the armor-piercing
bullet would tear through his body to be
specific the bullet would pierce through
both of flock's human legs and as he
stumbles backwards another shot would be
fired that would narrowly miss his spine
up in the sky evan would see all of this
happening and regardless of what the
mission is he'd know that he needs to do
something to prevent these soldiers
firing again
if the armor titan is killed here then
there's no guarantee ldl will ever get
it back and so the commander would
quickly intervene by stomping the entire
front entrance of the prison doing this
would be a risky move since the debris
could have potentially hurt sasha and
the others but luckily for them they'd
already be underground by now and would
be approaching the chamber where zeke
was killed back on the surface airman's
new priority is checking that flock is
alive and so his colossal titan will
begin to kneel down as he prepares to
exit his shifter the commander would be
completely surrounded by smoke as his
human body begins to emerge but just as
he's doing that a strange-looking titan
would ambush him out of nowhere this
creature would lunge towards irving with
its mouth wide open and at this moment
there's no way he'd be able to react in
time
anyhow while that was happening over in
shigachina aaron would be
single-handedly fighting against a swarm
of titans considering that in this
timeline he's had over half a year to
practice with his warhammer abilities it
shouldn't be too surprising that he'd
know how to create a handful of
different things in this particular
situation he'd use the hardening to
generate a sword as a weapon like this
makes it very simple to decapitate the
pure titans
simultaneously inside the fort there'd
be a ton of scouts getting themselves
ready with mikasa being desperate to
join the action before aaron gets
himself killed in a different section of
the fort historia would be looking out
the window as the attack titan continues
to fight and she'd be thinking back to
the last conversation they had before he
left during that conversation his story
would have begged him not to go outside
as she'd have a much more effective way
of stopping the enemy her proposal was
that right now they turn her into a
titan of royal blood which would allow
aaron to use the coordinate like he did
four years ago with that power he'd have
been able to take control of all titans
in shigachina and stop them from eating
people and aaron would even have to
acknowledge that this is the most
rational thing to do however when it
came down to it he wouldn't be able to
accept the idea of her being sacrificed
especially after he's already lost so
many people who were close to him that's
why he'd run outside to fight the global
alliance by himself because he knew that
the longer he stayed inside the fort the
more likely historia would be to give
herself the injection
now in case you're wondering about
louise and hitch these two would have
stayed behind to protect the queen which
is exactly what evan asked them to do
before he left that being said the
situation has changed a lot since then
and after watching aaron behead titans
for about 10 minutes hitch would decide
that she wants to get involved it's
worth remembering that in the main
timeline this character thought that her
most meaningful job as a soldier was
when she was pulling bodies out of the
rubble following that logic in this new
timeline she find even greater meaning
in using her titan powers to save lives
given that she can help more people than
she ever could as a human
for that reason after apologizing to
historia hitch would exit the fort and
immediately transform into her female
titan she then run through shiganshna
until she finally reaches erin and as
the two of them come face to face he
throw his warhammer sword in her
direction
like we already mentioned this thing is
way easier for slicing the nape and he'd
pass it to hitch because this is her
first time fighting pure titans in real
life
soon after this the attack titan would
create a new weapon to replace the one
he gave away and this time around he'd
form a bow and arrow to destroy the
airships above
earlier in the fight he wouldn't have
needed this weapon since there were just
pure titans attacking him from every
direction but now that hitch is here
he's trusting her to take care of the
close range threats so that he can
eliminate the airships overhead
from above willy would have been
watching all these events unfold and up
to this point he'd have found it really
disturbing to see aaron using his dead
sister's abilities in spite of that with
the attack titan now using the bow and
arrow willy would realize that there
isn't any more time to stand around and
he'd get the ball rolling on the final
phase of his revenge plan
seconds later both he and magath would
parachute out the sky and as they
descend towards walmaria aaron would use
his arrows to blow up all the remaining
ships
meanwhile over by the prison evan would
be about to get swallowed by this
mysterious titan but at the last moment
levi was swooping to save his life
a minute earlier the scouts would have
emerged from the underground after
finding zeke's remains and they'd arrive
on the surface just in time to see peak
transform
her new hybrid titan would be a mixture
of the carton beast and as she lunged
forward to eat the commander that's when
levi would react
following this the captain would charge
at peak pretty much straight away
because as we saw in part 3 he has a
personal vendetta against her for
killing hanji as a result he'd see this
encounter as the perfect chance to make
her suffer but from the sidelines evan
would try to remind him that she needs
to be taken alive
the commander would be eager to learn
more about who the warrior is working
with and what their motivations are but
the injured flock would argue that this
shouldn't be a priority with zeke now
being dead the entire island is a risk
so he'd argue that they should let levi
deal with peak while the rest of them
travel back home to make historia into a
titan in normal circumstances they might
have been able to send a transmission to
warner about the situation but when
irvin stomped on the prison it destroyed
the only radio they could have used
therefore flock's proposal would be to
quickly travel back to shiganshina and
if they're lucky they'll make it to the
queen before the enemy does
after considering this proposal the
commander would accept that titanizing
historia is by far the most urgent thing
for humanity and so he and the rest of
the scouts would begin their journey
back to the walls at the same time levi
would be left with the sole
responsibility of defeating the car
titan and ervin would give him orders to
bring her back alive if possible
switching back to aaron and hitch these
two will continue to stand strong
against the pure titans and they'd be
supported by dozens of scouts all across
the district however what nobody on the
ground would be aware of is that on top
of world maria mcgath would be finished
setting up his anti-titan sniper rifle
just like in the main series this
character would want revenge for
everything that happened in liberio but
beyond that he'd also want to save the
world by defeating the founding titan
of course the problem here is that if
mcgouth was to just kill eren then the
founder would be inherited by a random
elder baby somewhere in the world that
might potentially cause trouble for them
in the future so the better option is
for the alliance to steal the coordinate
for themselves
the first step to making that happen is
for aaron to be eaten by one of these
random titans and mcgath would need to
use his rifle to set things in motion
to start things off he'd aim for the
attack titan's head and fire off a super
precise shot that would disable aaron's
ability to move this would leave him
incredibly vulnerable but the pure
titans still wouldn't be able to get
close due to the female titan constantly
wiping them out
in order to solve this issue mcgather
asked for his rifle to be reloaded and
after a few seconds of concentration his
next shot would blow out the female
titan's nape this bullet would
completely shred through hitch's human
body killing her almost instantly and
inside the fort louise and historia
would have been watching the whole thing
anyway when it comes to levi and peak
these two would have been fighting each
other for a while and the captain would
be trying his best to finish her off
his main goal here would be to slice off
her human limbs but so far every single
time you get close pique would eject
herself from her titan and then generate
a new one
thanks to the cart having nearly
unlimited stamina she could keep going
for as long as she needs to and after
doing this around six or seven times
levi would be so exhausted that he'd
start to lose composure
realizing that his reactions are slowing
down pig would take advantage of this
weakness by abandoning the fight the
truth is that she never would have had
an interest in battling levi to the
death as she was more concerned with
preventing iron and flock from returning
to shiganchina her goal would be to kill
the armada and colossal titans before
they make it back to the walls which
would be her way of honouring reiner and
bertos memory
even though the scouts had a big head
start peak's beast title would enable
her to track the smell of flock's blood
and her shifter would be a lot faster
than the galloping horse for that reason
she'd eventually catch up to the group
while they were in a forest near the
walls and the very first person she'd
target would be the commander being
their leader that he is though he'd
ordered the other scouts to keep
charging forward regardless of what
happens to him especially sasha who'd
have been carrying the injured flock
this whole time in flock's current
condition he just wouldn't have the
energy to become the armored titan while
irvin himself transformed too recently
to be able to do it again
because of that he'd be a sitting dark
as peak lunges forward to kill him and
as he braces himself to get swallowed a
bright white light would suddenly flash
before his eyes when the light
disappears the card titan and everything
else around him would vanish while the
sky itself would abruptly change from
day to night
in this night sky there'd be a strange
aura unlike anything the commander has
seen in his life
not to mention mountains of sand that
would surround him for miles
after seeing all this evan's first
thought would be that he must be dead
since the last thing he'd remember was
peak chasing after him he then began to
wonder if this is some kind of illusion
and as he continues to think about all
the possibilities his trainer thought
would be interrupted by aaron
from behind he'd approach the commander
with a depressing look on his face and
evan would turn to ask him what this
place is and whether he was the one that
brought them there aaron would simply
reply by confirming that he wasn't the
one that did this and as evan now fully
turns around he'd witness his story
approaching him from the other side
with that said that is the end for part
four of what if evan got the colossal
titan and if you enjoyed this video then
be sure to drop a like and leave a
comment letting me know what you think
also don't forget to hit that sub button
so you'll be entered into the prize draw
and if you're lucky your comment will be
randomly selected
until the next one peace out